Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ja, rufen sie jetzt die Nummer neben ihrer Landeslage an, würde ich sagen.
Es ist alles weg, es ist alles weg, die erwähnten zwei Kilogramm MDMA äh volle sind längst äh weg. Ich denke nicht, dass es äh lange dauern wird, bis es wieder einen neuen,
Gibt's denn mehrere nach.
Gibt überhaupt keinen Mangel im Internet. Das ist das Schöne. Ne, trotz alledem äh so äh,
kriminelle Machenschaften im Internet sind jetzt auch nicht unnachvollziehbar. Dem sollte man sich doch immer mal wieder äh klar werden. Naja.
Komm mal, komm mal gleich.
Ja, ansonsten äh die Pause hier in der Metaebene ist äh äh vorbei. Und jetzt wird wieder fleißig äh gesammelt und zusammengefegt und äh äh
Natürlich auch hier bei Logbuch Netzpolitik und wir schreiben die einundachtzigste Sendung und es ist der zwölfte Oktober zwanzig dreizehn,
gucken, ob ich mich dann auch noch mal dran gewöhne. Mit dem Datum. Und die Frage ist, was gibt's Neues, Linus?
Es gibt es gibt einiges neues, es gibt vor allem etwas neues vom europäischen,
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Und zwar gab's da ein eine ganz interessante.
Äh äh einen komischen Fall, also eine eine,
News-Seite hat irgendwie einen Bericht geschrieben über Eisbrecher und deren negativen Einfluss auf Pläne Autostraßen zu einigen,
Inseln vor der Küste einzurichten,
Ja und äh auf ja, aus irgendwelchen Gründen entwickelte sich dann unter diesem Artikel ein kleiner Shitstorm auf den, einen Hauptanteilseigner der Fährbetreiberfirma,
ja? Also äh ja so,
Ich kann halt nicht esnisch, aber mir scheint mir so, dass halt die Fährenbetreiber natürlich irgendwie dagegen arbeiten, dass äh Brücken gebaut werden, weil sie ja Fähren
betreiben und dann gab's halt irgendwie einige unflätige Kommentare zu zu der Person,
dieser dieser einzelnen Personen. Das war die war also im in äh in Augen einiger Kommentatoren und Kommentatorinnen eben ein ein ein unwürdiger Mensch, ja? Und wurde dann irgendwie beschimpft. Ähm
dann hat dieser diese betroffene Person, die also in den Kommentaren auf dieser News-Seite äh beleidigt wurde, ähm,
Die Betreiber dieser Seite aufgefordert, das irgendwie zu löschen und die haben das auch gelöscht. Man würde jetzt meinen.
Damit ist doch dann alles gut.
Genau und so verläuft der äh so verläuft das ja in Deutschland üblicherweise, also du machst, du hast irgendwie äh ein ein scheiß Kommentar, ja? Und du haftest erstmal nicht dafür,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass du darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt wirst. Das heißt, äh in dem Moment, wo sich jemand über einen eventuell äh was weiß ich, auf irgendeine Weise rechtswidrigen Kommentar,
Auf einer Seite der Metaebene bei dir beklagt,
Bist du darüber in Kenntnis gesetzt? Und ab dem Moment bist du dafür haftbar. Ja? Das heißt du kannst eine Kommentarfunktion laufen lassen ähm ohne sie anzuschauen und zu moderieren.
Aber du musst halt reagieren, wenn dich jemand darauf hinweist, dass da was.
Und zwar dann unverzüglich, weil da ein bisschen Kenntnis gesetzt und in dem Moment haftest du quasi, ja? Finde ich eigentlich eine eine sinnvolle Regelung, ja, also äh ich betreibe ja auch offene Kommentarplattformen und ähm,
wenn mich da jemand drauf hinweisen würde, dass da irgendwas nicht äh gefällt, dann würde ich da natürlich äh sofort eine eine Löschung fahren lassen. Und ansonsten kümmere ich mich einfach nicht darum.
Ja? So und jetzt bekam aber diese äh dieser der Betreiber der Seite eine Geldstrafe von einem estnischen Gericht.
Mit der Begründung, dass überhaupt diese,
Ekel, also diese die Meinung oder die Person verletzenden Kommentare veröffentlicht wurden, hätte ähm diese Seite verhindern müssen,
und ihr wurde auch weiterhin zur Last gelegt, dass sie nicht äh die Kommentare aus Eigeninitiative entfernt hat, sondern noch darauf hingewiesen werden musste, ja? Also mit anderen Worten,
denen wurde gesagt, ihr ähm ihr seid dafür verantwortlich und es ist euer Fehler, dass ihr nicht,
Das einfach äh dass ihr das nicht von vorne rein kontrolliert habt. Ja, also mit anderen Worten, ihr seid gezwungen dazu, ähm das zu moderieren und ja, in zu kontrollieren, was die Leute da schreiben,
und dann ging dieser Fall eben vor den äh IGMR,
und der hat zugestimmt und sagt ja ähm abgesehen davon hat diese News-Seite ja irgendwie einen finanziellen Vorteil aus den Nutzerkommentaren. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie wie der aussieht. Ähm.
Kann man das jetzt monetarisieren.
Keine Ahnung, äh also na ich man könnte vielleicht argumentieren, dass die Leute, die da kommentieren, die Seite dann wieder neu besuchen, weil sie sich ja mit anderen streiten und deshalb mehr zu für mehr Klicks sorgen.
Dann mehr Werbung sehen.
Ja
Und die ganze Zeit kaufen, wie die blöden.
Ja oder in dem Fall dadurch, dass der Fall vielleicht irgendwie so eine hohe Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat, dass dann da alle nochmal draufgeklickt haben oder so. Deswegen die Seite offen. Keine Ahnung,
aber.
Nicht so ganz hin, wenn du mich fragst.
Die Begründung ist ja, sie hätten sie hätten aktive Maßnahmen ergreifen müssen, die nicht zu veröffentlichen, beziehungsweise äh äh selbst,
selbständig äh ohne Hinweis zu entfernen. Mit anderen Worten, sie müssen ihre eigenen ähm müssen ihre Kommentarplattform da unten äh moderieren äh bis zensieren.
Jetzt frage ich mich natürlich grade, was hat eigentlich dieser Europäische Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte ausgerechnet äh in dieser Entscheidungskette da zu suchen? Also inwiefern betrifft denn das hier Menschenrechte? Und inwiefern ist denn das jetzt äh bindend
Also
für wen und auf welcher Ebene, also das scheint mir ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass das jetzt nicht beim normalen Gerichtshof gelandet ist, weil das ja zunächst einmal eine ganz normale Zivilklagen,
Kette äh ist also Menschenrechte, welches Menschenrecht ist denn hier verletzt worden?
Ich denke, dass es dass es ein äh.
Hm. Ich war ja im Urlaub. Ich konnte das ja nicht. Ja, ja.
Ich war ja im Urlaub. Ich konnte das ja nicht nachlesen, deswegen kann ich dir jetzt hier solche äh tricky Fragen stellen.
Ähm.
Es ging in dem äh also der die die Begründung warum es dort war, ist weil es um freie Meinungsäußerung ging. Und deswegen ist der EGMR dann betroffen, ja? Weil sie sagen ähm.
Also dass ja grundsätzlich in dem in dem das grundsätzlich freie Meinungsäußerung herrscht und dass sie deswegen nicht äh gezwungen werden können, alle diese Kommentare zu äh zu moderieren,
ja? Und das ist auch der das ist auch der, der wichtige der wichtige Einschnitt, der daraus ähm,
der damit einhergeht. Also vielleicht macht's ja intuitiv sogar Sinn, dass man sagt, na ja, hör mal, wenn du eine Webseite betreibst und da können Leute was hinschreiben, dann muss sie irgendwie aufpassen, was da steht.
Und das bist du dafür verantwortlich. Immerhin sind's deine Server, die diese Inhalte dann übertragen
und wenn du anderen Menschen ermöglichst, da was reinzuschreiben, dann musst du es eben kontrollieren. Und wenn dann da jemand den den Holocaust leugnet oder so, dann bist du eben daran schuld.
Ja, aber dann muss ja auch noch jemand das Internet die ganze Zeit lesen, das reicht auch schon, dass so viel geschrieben wird.
Ich denke, das Problem ist ein anderes. Wenn du wenn du wenn du hingehst und sagst, okay jeder der Kommentare veröffentlicht,
muss die moderieren und ist grundsätzlich dafür verantwortlich, ja? Das heißt, also, wie gesagt, so in dem Fall jetzt Beleidigung einer Person, kriege ich eine, kriege ich als Betreiber der Seite eine Geldstrafe für. Als nächstes geht da einer hin und leugnet den Holocaust,
bin ich ja auch noch für verantwortlich, ja? Und irgendwann bin ich halt verurteilter Holocaust-Leugner oder so, ja, weil ich einen Server betrieben habe, auf dem in irgendein Kommentar irgendjemand irgendeinen Scheiß behauptet hat.
Schönes Einnahmemodell für Staaten äh sozusagen einfach alle Blogs mit äh maximal.
Ja oder auch, ist doch auch ein schönes Geschäftsmodell.
Leidigen Inhalt zu füllen, ne?
Gehe ich halt über ein Anonymisierungsnetzwerk irgendwohin und beleidige mich selber und zeig dann den den Seitenbetreiber an.
Aber da kriegst du doch nicht die Kohle.
Wenn ich beleidigt wurde?
Ach so, ach so diese ach so diese das Geld ging nicht ans Gericht.
Nee, nee, das also ja, weiß ich jetzt. Also ich denke mal, dass also es ging um eine.
Ja Geldstrafe geht ja an den Staat und das andere wäre ja sozusagen nochmal eine Schmerzensgeld.
Ich will jetzt mal ganz kurz erstmal auf den wichtigen Punkt.
Ja.
Wenn der Betreiber verpflichtet ist, rechtswidrige Kommentare zu entfernen, beziehungsweise nicht gar nicht erst zuzulassen. Das ist ja der Unterschied. Der hat die ja entfernt. Ja, und es war nicht genug.
Es ist unmöglich zu machen.
So, es ist unmöglich zu machen und selbst wenn du es machst, dann wird die Rationale dabei sein, dass du,
Kommentare im Zweifel nicht zulässt. Also weil du ja nicht das Risiko eingehen möchtest, sagen wir mal, da steht jetzt einer und hat eine nur bedingt noch durch Fakten gedeckte Aussage, die er da tätigt.
Ähm oder für dich eben nicht mehr im Rahmen des nachprüfbaren äh stehende Aussage, dann würdest du dir im Zweifelsfall lieber nicht zulassen, weil du als Betreiber nicht das Risiko eingehen möchtest,
für dich ähm äh diese Äußerung anzunehmen.
Es ist vor allem generell eigentlich unmöglich, überhaupt noch irgendetwas zuzulassen, weil du dir eigentlich bei gar nichts sicher sein kannst
kannst, ob nicht irgendein Recht verletzt wird, weil dann müsstest du ja im Prinzip in Kenntnis jeglicher Rechtsprechung sein und
wissen, was sie bedeutet und was sie in diesem Fall konkret macht. Also jeder müsse sozusagen
jedem im Internet abgegebenen Kommentar das komplette Rechtswissen seines Staates oder vielleicht sogar Europas äh durchdekliniert bekommen innerhalb von null Komma fünf äh Mikrosekunden, wo diese Entscheidung fällt und das ist einfach überhaupt nicht äh zumutbar. Ich meine, dafür haben wir Gerichte
dass sie dann im Zweifelsfall auch mal feststellen, äh was denn jetzt hier äh auch wirklich das angewandte Gesetz ist und nicht selten haben wir ja auch schon,
eigentlich Situationen, wo auch Dinge entschieden werden, wo man sich denkt so, äh wie,
Das lese ich aber hier irgendwie anders in den Paragraphen.
Ja, wir also wir haben, wir haben genau dieses, ich meine, die die Gegenseite würde natürlich sagen,
Es kann doch wohl nicht sein, dass jeder Mensch mich irgendwie im Internet beleidigen kann und ich aufräumen muss,
ähm und und und die Leute, die das alles veröffentlichen und zur Verbreitung beitragen nicht dafür verantwortlich sind.
Zeitungen genauso. Also ich meine, was unterscheidet das Internet an der Stelle von äh von dem echten, von dem echten Leben?
Naja, wenn ich äh wenn eine Zeitung etwas äh etwas nachweislich bösartiges oder Gelogenes über mich schreibt, dann kann kriegt sie auch eine Strafe dafür und nicht nur äh irgendwie rechts zu Gegenerstellung oder so.
Na ja, also auf jeden Fall also es ist ein problematischer.
Also es ist ein es ist ein es ist ein sehr problematisches Urteil und es hätte naja vor allem das ist jetzt hier einfach mal äh die äh ein EGMR-Urteil, ja.
Das heißt, äh das heißt letztendlich, ähm wenn das jetzt zur Schule macht und sich und das jetzt irgendwie so umgesetzt wird, dass dass man eine Kommentarspalte sich echt bald nicht mehr erlauben kann.
Und das wiederum wird äh,
Ja gut, kannst ja, du kannst ja eine Webseite ohne Kommentare machen. Aber äh ich weiß noch nicht genau, ob denen ganz klar ist, was das zum Beispiel für Facebook bedeutet, wenn man das, also ich kann mir irgendwie nicht vorstellen, dass das eine ernstzunehmende.
Stimmt.
Das ist irgendwie nicht ganz klar, also vor allem, dass sie dann sagen, so äh also mir leuchtet das nicht wirklich ein,
Also es.
Es ist irgendwie nicht äh klar, was also äh es kann eigentlich so nicht ähm bestehen, also wenn du das so sagst, ne, wenn also wenn meine Güte, jetzt bin ich ja ganz, ganz wuschig. Also,
Das Internet kann so nicht funktionieren und ein ein solche Rechtsprechung kann auch nicht funktionieren.
Ich zitiere mal kurz die Wikipedia,
Artikel Europäischer Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte, Bindungswirkung der Urteile des EGMR in Deutschland. Da heißt es in Deutschland steht die,
EMRK, was ist das jetzt wieder für eine Abkürzung? Äh europäische Menschenrechtskonvention äh im Rang unter dem Grundgesetz, sie können,
Auf der Ebene eines einfaches Bundesgesetztes. Sie kann daher vor deutschen Gerichten wie jedes andere Gesetz geltend gemacht werden kann. Also die Menschenrechts,
Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt eine Aussage über die Urteile gewesen. Äh okay. Ich der Rest äh enthält mir zu viele Paragraphen, um das jetzt hier zu zitieren. Ich lasse einfach mal offen. Ähm es gibt da auf jeden Fall eine
Bindungswirkung,
die nochmal interessant wäre vielleicht auch hier bei uns in den Kommentaren, falls sich da jemand auskennt, bevor wir wieder dummes Zeug äh reden. Ähm,
was denn seiner ihrer Meinung nach da für eine Bindungswirkung hier jetzt in Kraft treten könnte durch dieses Urteil.
Also man würde eigentlich erwarten oder eigentlich sind waren solche Debatten inzwischen mal äh hatte hatte man eigentlich gedacht, das hätten wir inzwischen hinter uns. Und die Regelungen äh mit,
wie es in Deutschland eben in den letzten Jahren so war, in Kenntnis setzen, meistens kriegst du dann irgendwie so eine Fristsetzung oder sowas. Ähm und das einfach auf einen kurzen Dienstweg zu klären, halte ich für ähm für eine sinnvolle,
Möglichkeit hier das, das Recht einer einer Person äh und das das Vorgut der Meinungsfreiheit irgendwie in eine Abwägung zu bringen,
und äh das scheint hier jetzt krass,
In dieser in dieser Rechtsprechung in diesem Urteil nicht der Fall zu sein und das könnte sehr unangenehme Folgen haben, wenn das so jetzt irgendwie Schule macht.
Ja, also alles Facebook.
Ja
Alles zu Facebook ist eine schöne Idee, haben ja auch äh machen ja viele Firmen und das ist eines der, ich glaube, das haben wir so in den in den ersten Folgen Lokbuch Netzpolitik mit einer irgendwie,
ein oder zwei, mit einer einstelligen Episodenzahl oder so. Da haben wir darüber schon gesprochen, dass äh der,
Tilo Weichert ähm vom äh ULD unabhängiges Landeszentrum für den Datenschutz,
in Schleswig-Holstein.
Auch als Datenschutz Taliban bezeichnet. Von wegen? Von verschiedenen Menschen.
Von wem? Das ist zum Beispiel jetzt ein anonymer Kommentar, der der ist den hast du dir jetzt zu eigen gemacht. Dafür stehst du jetzt.
Ich habe nur gesagt, dass ich das gehört habe, dass das irgendjemand gesagt hat.
Aber du machst du machst hier eindeutig finanziellen Profit.
Da kann man ja sagen, was man will, oder? Habe ich das jetzt falsch verstanden? Hier ging's auch nur um Kommentare.
Also Thilo Weichert hat damals äh ist hingegangen und hat gesagt, ja ähm hat irgendwie dreizehn Unternehmen in Schleswig-Holstein angeschrieben und hat gesagt, so ich verordne hiermit,
dass ihr äh eure Facebook-Seiten schließen müsst, weil,
Facebook erstellt äh Profile über die Menschen und und verletzt ähm
deutsche Datenschutzgesetz stimmt und zwar massiv stimmt und wenn ihr als äh Firmen die Menschen dorthin euren eure Kontakte,
den Menschen dorthin outsourct, dann äh steht ihr da in der Verantwortung. Und deswegen äh dürft ihr keine Facebook-Seiten haben,
für eure für euren Kundenkontakt,
Ja und dann haben äh die diese dreizehn oder es waren, glaube ich, dreizehn Unternehmen. Und da haben dann äh die diese drei von diesen Schleswig-Holsteiner und Holsteiner Unternehmen haben gesagt, na ja,
Das sehen wir irgendwie nicht unbedingt ein, weil das dann wirklich zu einem äh,
nachweislichen Nachteil für uns führt gegenüber Unternehmen, die in anderen Bundesländern sind und.
Und gerade deutschlandweit plakatieren mit Facebook äh URLs äh et cetera. Ja, ja. Mhm.
Ähm und jetzt landete dieser Fall dann vorm Oberverwaltungsgericht äh,
Nee, äh im Verwaltungsgericht noch nicht im Oberverwaltungsgericht. Ähm,
In Schleswig-Holstein. Warte, jetzt muss ich nochmal kurz mit den Gerichten habe ich's ja immer, das ist ja immer schwierig. Äh der Verwaltungsgericht Schleswig. Ähm,
Und das hat das sein das Verbot von Firmenseiten bei Facebook aufgehoben. Das heißt, die haben Recht bekommen dürfen. Das heißt, der äh das unabhängige Landesschutzzentrum für den Datenschutz hat verloren. Vor Gericht.
Und was war dann sozusagen die Empfehlung, dass äh sie sich doch bitte an Facebook direkt wenden sollen?
Ähm ich bin ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, sie haben einfach gesagt, ja ähm,
Na, na, na, na, na. Ich bin mir.
Sie haben einfach also verhandelt wurde ja nicht, dass das Datenschutzmodell von Facebook, sondern verhandelt wurde, ob sich die Unternehmen, die eine Facebook-Fanseite äh betreiben,
Äh schuldig quasi an den Datenschutzverletzungen machen, die Facebook betreibt,
und das war nicht der Fall,
Also sie haften nicht für die äh für die für die Datenschutzvergehen, äh die ihr Erfüllungsgehilfe Facebook äh in diesem Falle äh begeht.
Ja, ich weiß ja, das ist halt vor vor dem Hintergrund der äh äh,
der Debatten der letzten der letzten Wochen erscheint das natürlich ein bisschen ähm äh ein bisschen lächerlich dieser ganze dieser ganze Fall, aber das hat schon ich meine, er hat da einen Punkt, ja, so es es ist,
aus Datenschutzerwägung nicht unbedingt irgendwie zu rechtfertigen, dass ein Unternehmen,
seine Kunden oder was?
Zu Facebook, zu Facebook Nutzung anstiftet, ja? Und dass dieser ganze Kram dann da irgendwie bei auf anderen Servern liegt, unterm anderen Datenschutzgesetz, da verwaltet wird, ähm Facebook natürlich Profile über die Nutzer macht, das ist das Modell
Also ich finde es grundsätzlich schon auch ziemlich schlechten Stil für ein Unternehmen, eine Facebook-Seite zu haben,
Ja? Äh das wird die Marketingabteilung des Unternehmens anders sehen.
Ja.
Daran erkennt man meistens schlechten Stil.
Aber ähm.
Na klar, nee, aber es sind natürlich auch Zwänge. Also, ich meine, äh weißt ja, wie das ist.
Genau, ich habe euch nicht auf Facebook gefunden. Also ja, also ich kenne aber der.
Ich will das jetzt auch gar nicht bewerten. Ich äh sag nur, das das ist halt einfach das Problem.
Ich würde gerne, ich würde halt sicherstellen, sind oder ich würde gerne feststellen, so der äh Thilo Weichert hat da durchaus einen Punkt,
Ähm allerdings dann mit irgendeiner Schleswig-Holstein-Richtlinie und fünfzigtausend Euro Strafe äh da aufzutreten. Ähm da hat er sich.
Nicht unbedingt hier angemessenste Variante, ne.
Hat er sich ein bisschen zu weit aus dem äh Fenster gelegt.
Ja, ich habe jetzt gerade mal geguckt, wo wir schon über äh das Thema ULD gesprochen haben. Im einstelligen Bereich habe ich jetzt nichts gefunden, aber wir hatten Anfang des Jahres äh in ähm Politik neunundvierzig mit dem schönen Titel, berechtigtes Interesse,
ein Kapitel gehabt, der diesen Streit zwischen dem ULD und Facebook äh nochmal näher beleuchtet.
Ja
Ja, also das ähm äh ja, was soll man dazu sagen?
Natürlich können sich da jetzt grade ein paar Leute sehr drüber amüsieren, ähm dass äh dass,
radikal oder ich sage mal, die schon noch die die einer der stärksten Datenschützer im im Lande da jetzt so eine Bauchlandung hingelegt.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, auch das setzt ja wieder klar, es war jetzt ein interessanter Hebel und man kann natürlich auch durchaus argumentieren, so hey, ihr habt da einen Dienstleister, um das mal anders zu formulieren, ja, für eure Informationssammlung
ja nicht Facebook als Identität, sondern einfach so, ihr benutzt da,
so ein Skript, so ein Tool, so eine Kommentarfunktion, ja? Könnt ihr ja jetzt auch irgendwas anderes sein und das äh ist nicht das Richtige,
Sind wir wieder so ein bisschen wie im letzten Kapitel schon. Woher soll ich das beurteilen können?
Ja, also klar
steht in den Medien, was steht da nicht alles, ja? Äh muss ich jetzt mir die komplette Rechtsprechung äh äh geben, solange Facebook als Anbieter auf dem Markt das nur nicht komplett weggeklagt worden ist und nicht sonst wie äh ja, also wenn wenn das so eklatant
Hatte Verletzungen sind, ja, warum kann man denn nicht direkt gegen das Unternehmen vorgehen?
Jetzt ich argumentiere jetzt nur so aus der Sicht dieser Unternehmen heraus, ja? Muss ich jetzt eine komplette Rechtsüberprüfung sämtlicher Geschäftsvorgänge jeglicher Firma vornehmen,
denen ich irgendwie eine Dienstleistung in Anspruch nehme? Das geht nicht. Ja, das ist so ein bisschen wie mit diesen Kommentaren, das das kann man von mir jetzt nicht erwarten.
Und daher finde ich das jetzt auch absolut äh nachvollziehbar in seiner ähm Entstehungsgeschichte.
Ja, so sieht's auf jeden Fall aus und ähm das ULD äh erwägt jetzt da in Berufung zu gehen und das Ganze irgendwie vorn Oberverwaltungsgericht zu tragen.
Interessant werden.
Ja
So, wie sieht's denn bei unseren Freunden vom Schlapphüten aus? Gibt's da nichts neues?
Doch natürlich gibt's auch was Neues. Ähm das war jetzt, wenn ich mich nicht täusche, im Spiegel,
ähm,
Wo es dann hieß, ja, seit ungefähr seit mindestens zwei Jahren, schickt der äh BND Bundesnachrichtendienst eine dreiseitige Anordnung zur strategischen Fernmeldeaufklärung an,
den Eco, den Verband der Internetwirtschaft. Und das ist also eine Anordnung, die unterschrieben ist von Bundeskanzleramt und Bundesinnenministerium,
und äh sagt, darin wird also angeordnet, dass fünfundzwanzig Provider,
der strategischen Fernmeldeaufklärung unterzogen werden sollen. Die.
Der BD schickt immer wieder dieselbe Anordnung.
So so sehe ich das, ja, die ist wahrscheinlich, die gilt dann wahrscheinlich immer für eine bestimmte Zeit oder sowas, ja? Äh so, so. Nee, nee, nee, nee, ne.
Ach so. Also nicht vergeblich, sondern die wird nur regelmäßig wieder erneuert.
So klingt das so. Und die strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung hatten wir ähm auch hier im Lokbusch schon äh mindest, also schon mehrere Male behandelt. So zur Erinnerung, ich glaube, das hatte ich,
Äh als die ganzen Snowden Sachen losgingen, hatten wir da auf jeden Fall mal drüber gesprochen. Und äh wir haben darüber gesprochen, dass die irgendwann mal vor ein paar Jahren so ein Problem hatten äh mit Spam klarzukommen.
Äh denn die strategische Fernmeldeaufklärung äh,
passiert anhand einer Schlagwortsuche. Ja, die Schlagwortliste ist aber geheim, okay, leuchtet ein, stehen wahrscheinlich so Sachen drauf wie Bombe und äh,
Terror oder so was, ja.
Ja, wir hatten das am elften Juni äh dieses Jahres in der Lokbuchnetzpolitik siebenundsechzig.
Vor, haben wir irgendwann. Weißt du?
Als es um Prizn äh äh ging. Schon lange nichts mehr auf NSA gepostet. Ist die Sendung.
Wir haben auch vorher schon mal darüber gesprochen. Also da ging's darum, dass sie, die hatten halt irgendwann mal ein Jahr lang, da war dann das Gelächter groß, hatten sie große Probleme, weil sie mit Spaming irgendwie nicht mehr klar gekommen sind,
und ähm das funktioniert, wie gesagt, es äh ist äh eine äh funktioniert anhand von Schlagwörtern, so viel ist klar
und ähm man weiß aber nicht genau, wie lange die da speichern und was die speichern, ja?
Und jetzt wurde das irgendwie so bekannt und ähm es wurden von den fünfundzwanzig Providern
namentlich genannt eins und eins Strato QSC, Lambdanet und Plus-Server. Ja, aber das sind jetzt eben sechs von den fünfundzwanzig. Ähm.
Woraufhin dann irgendwie Eins und Eins äh eine Pressemitteilung raus gehabt, dass sie davon nichts wissen und äh davon ausgehen, dass das beim Dezix gemacht wird, also beim,
ähm Central Internet Exchange oder heißt das heißt das steht das C bei Six für Central? Nee. Cummen, oder?
Gute Frage. Hat sich das nicht sogar irgendwann mal geändert? Commercial Internet ist.
Commercial, ah. Äh und eigentlich hieß es mal Computing äh Exchange.
Ist das hervorgegangen. Das weiß ich nicht mehr ganz genau.
Ja, da.
Computer-Link. Weiß ich nichts von.
Na, nee, das ist irgendwas ganz anderes, was ich jetzt hier,
Äh nee, das ist was anderes. Das war das hat nichts mit den Zixen zu tun. Egal, also ähm,
Mit anderen Worten, der BND hängt beim Dezix und äh,
mache da Traffic Überwachung. Nach Schlagworten. Das war ja eigentlich auch schon immer klar. Der entscheidende Punkt ist, dass es von allen Beteiligten andauernd geleugnet wurde. Der
Dezix hat ja auch schon immer gesagt, ja, nee, hier und so weiter, wir reden über nichts und hier passiert nix und keine Ahnung, aber natürlich äh ist ja so eine Anordnung eh mit äh Geheimhaltung,
verbunden. Aber jetzt kommt der interessante Teil. Wir reden ja hier vom Bundesnachrichtendienst. Der, wie wir wissen, der deutsche Auslandsgeheimdienst ist.
In Deutschland eigentlich nix abzuschnorcheln hat.
Der hat in Deutschland nichts abzuschnorcheln. Und die Meldung ist schon etwas älter,
Und zwar im August äh gab's dann schon die Meldung, dass da gefragt wurde, na ja hör mal, wenn ihr da irgendwie in einem Traffic rumschnorchelt und ihr ja keine Deutschen überwachen dürft,
Ähm wie macht denn ihr das? So, ne? Das war ja die NSA hat das ja irgendwie mit einem er hat das ja gesagt so äh wenn es mehr als fünfzig Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit ist, dass du ähm nicht Amerikaner bist, also etwas besser als Münzwurf,
dann äh dürfen wir dich abholen,
Und äh die die äh in Deutschland kursierte dann das Gerücht, dass sie sagen, na ja, dass die deutsche E-Mail Adressen am Punkt DE erkennen.
Ja und und ähm die Telefonnummern an dem an der Plus neunundvierzig,
Also man weiß es nicht und äh so viel ist glaube ich sinnvoll zu sagen, die können das auch nicht erkennen. Ja, dass äh so viel weiß ich über Datenstrom, dass du das nicht
äh sinnvoll äh detektieren kannst. Ob das jetzt grade eine E-Mail von einer von einem deutschen Bundesbürger ist oder äh von einem.
Vollkommen ausgeschlossen. Ich meine, man sieht ja schon, welche Probleme äh Deutschland hat so mit elektronischem Personalausweisen und so weiter überhaupt mal eine Identifizierung eines deutschen hinzubekommen, dann kriegen sie das auf gar keinen Fall hin, wenn sie sich da in Turbogeschwindigkeit
monströse Datenströme äh vor die Nase legen.
Und jetzt kommt noch ein ein anderer interessanter Punkt zur Sprache. Auch das hatten wir im Logbuch erzählt, dass die teilweise ähm also dass sie ja mehr Geld haben wollten. Das war auch gerade kurz nach dem NSA-Skandal. Da wollten sie auf einmal hundert Millionen haben,
Das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch die Folge, die du gerade angesprochen hattest. Äh wo sie nämlich sagen, ja ähm wir dürfen ja nach dem G zehn Gesetz irgendwie zwanzig Prozent und wir kommen da aber gar nicht dran, wir schaffen meistens nur fünf.
Und deswegen müssen wir die Kapazitäten ausbauen. Und jetzt ist interessant, wovon überhaupt zwanzig Prozent. Ja, von,
der Gesamtübertragungskapazität des Dezix und oder von der,
tatsächlichen Last des Dezixs. Ja, also wenn man sagt,
Wenn ich sage, ich darf zwanzig Prozent der Übertragungskapazität des Dezix abschnorcheln und der Dezix läuft im Durchschnitt einfach auf zwanzig Prozent seiner Gesamtkapazität, dann darf ich ja hundert Prozent vom gesamten machen,
oder muss ich quasi meine meine zwanzig Prozent Regel immer daran definieren, wie viel gerade los ist beim DTX, also quasi so das das,
dessen,
Bandbreit hoch Meter, was da steht, definiert davon null Komma äh davon äh null Komma zwei oder so. Auch irgendwie völlig ungeklärte äh ungeklärte Fragen, zu denen keiner eine sinnvolle Antwort geben kann.
Haben sie so einen Schnorchelometer da immer.
Schnorchel.
Wo man dann immer genau sieht, wie viel jetzt grade noch äh abgespalten werden darf.
Ich kann da also wie gesagt, es ist ein bisschen unklar, weil der, weil die Dezix-Leute ja auch sagen, ja, nee, hm, nee, nee. Ähm,
Wir haben damit nix zu tun. Ähm,
Es ist genau das, was man immer äh erwartet hat und auch was auch Verschwörungstheoretisch einfach äh naheliegend ist, dass sie natürlich da an bestimmten Switches am Monitoring-Port hängen und da einfach mal ein bisschen rumschnorcheln. Wir hatten,
darüber auch, wie gesagt, es ist relativ viel Wiederholung. Wir haben,
in einer der letzten Folgen auch mal darüber gesprochen, ähm dass die wir auch nicht möchtest, dass der Provider, bei dem du abschnorchelst, erkennen kann, was du abschnorchelst.
Das heißt natürlich wollen die alles haben, damit ihre
Wortliste da nicht irgendwie jeden jeden Montag Morgen an fünfundzwanzig Pro weitergefaxt werden muss, ja?
Sondern sie wollen einfach mal Mirror haben von äh von allem Traffic und dann da selber ihre Analysen so durchführen,
dass nicht jemand anders das sehen kann.
Wenn sie wirklich bei abgreifen, dann ja, bleibt nach wie vor offen so. Also wenn ihr sagt, findet nicht statt und hier gibt's Berichte, es findet aber statt und fragt man sich natürlich, was findet denn jetzt eigentlich statt?
Das ist äh total äh offen, wenn die Abschnorchelung äh der Provider nur bei Dezex stattfindet, wenn es dort stattfindet, wir wissen es nicht,
Heißt das, dass sozusagen der Traffic innerhalb eines Providers nicht beschnorchelt wird.
Ähm.
Es weiß man eben nicht. Also Markus hat dann äh Markus Beckerdal hat beim beim DCX angerufen und hat dann so gesagt, ja wie ist das denn
Wenn man jetzt, wie sieht das denn bei euch aus? Dann müsste ich ja eigentlich an jeden Switch irgendwie mich nochmal an den Monitoringport hängen, wenn ich alles haben will. Und die Antwort war, ja, da wäre der technische Aufwand sehr hoch,
Ja, mit anderen Worten, ähm.
Keine Ahnung. Ja.
Sage ich nicht.
Aber so sehen, so sieht das aus. Also äh ich glaube, ich hatte das ja auch mal erzählt, dass ich, ja, das habe ich alles schon erzählt, dass ich mal in so einem äh beim Provider äh in so einem Netzwerk knoten war,
So und da habe ich dann auch gesagt, zeigt doch mal hier euer Love ful Inter Sep und das waren einfach nur Switches.
Gar nix. Da da stand nicht irgendein Gerät. Ich habe gedacht, krass, jetzt gucke ich mir mal an, wer das gebaut hat oder so, das waren einfach Switches und da gingen dann wieder Kabel raus, woanders hin,
einfach schön immer den und fertig ja so sieht's aus.
Die die die deutschen Provider haben ja jetzt die haben ja angekündigt, dass wir jetzt sowieso äh,
Wie haben sie das genannt, einen einen nationales E-Mail Überwachungsrings schaffen wollen.
Auch da haben wir schon so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen, da bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das wie sinnvoll das überhaupt ist, was.
Telekom hat das vorgeschlagen, ne?
Telekom hat vorgeschlagen.
Nationale E-Mail.
Ja, Telekom ist da jetzt ganz weit vorne. Sie haben ja erstmal haben sie ja schon vor vor Wochen, wir hatten darüber gelacht, äh gesagt, jetzt machen wir mal äh Transportwegverschlüsselung an,
zwischen den zwischen irgendwie United Internet GMX Web DE und und T Online.
Genau, wir benutzen die Web-Standards, die seit zehn Jahren da sind.
Genau, wir benutzen Werbständer jetzt, die seit zehn Jahren da sind und machen dann irgendwie eine, eine Deutschlandflagge mit mitm Schloss irgendwie in die Web-Oberfläche, über die die Leute unverschlüsselt ihre E-Mails dann da abholen, ja? Also totaler, totaler äh Firlefanz.
Ja, wie wollen sie das auch noch steigern, ne? Was kommt als nächstes? Stacheldraht.
Und jetzt sagen sie, wenn Sender und Empfänger in Deutschland sind, wollen wir jetzt erreichen, dass der Internetverkehr auch in Deutschland bleibt. Da frage ich mich.
Woher wollen sie das wissen?
Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt nicht sicher, dass die ähm.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nicht schon wieder so eine, so eine, so eine Nebelkerze ist,
stehen doch, die stehen doch eh die die Daten sind, die die stehen noch beide in Frankfurt. So und die werden doch bescheuert, äh das wird das wird, würden die allein schon aus ökonomischen Erwägungen nicht machen, den Traffic einmal durch die USA leiten und wieder nach Frankfurt.
Keine Wahl. Ich meine, wenn da eine Mail äh ist und da soll die Mail hin, dann haben sie das an den Rechner zu liefern, wo drauf steht, wo das hinzuliefern.
Sie könnten ja, sie könnten ja trotzdem eine Route äh definiert haben, wenn ich nebenan zu GMX schicke, dann gehe ich einmal durch die USA. Dort könnten sie ja durchaus äh haben.
Wenn sie blöd wären, weil das würde sie natürlich kosten. Das würde sie ja äh Transitkosten.
Macht eh alles keinen Sinn, also auch schon aus den normalen Kostenerwägungen her sollten Sie das so sehr in Ihrem eigenen Netz oder zumindest in äh Netzen, wo Sie klare äh die Foldpeerings äh haben, also wo Sie quasi,
bezahlen oder nichts bezahlen
das sollte eh so sein, nur wenn du halt jetzt da draufsteht, dass äh Dinos seine E-Mail über Tralala Punkt Tubalou äh empfängt und der Server steht in der Ukraine, dann hat da halt die Mail auch hinzugehen, weil sonst kann sie halt nicht zugestellt werden.
Ja was geht? Also.
Oder? Sehe ich grade irgendwas falsch.
Die ich frage mich einfach.
Und dieses Rauting wäre ja dann sozusagen auch wirklich auf IP-Ebenen hätte mit Mail erstmal so gar nichts zu tun.
Richtig, deswegen denke ich auch, also eigentlich würde man doch erwarten, dass die sowieso ein Kabel rüber gelegt haben und am genau am Dezex, wo der BND steht, äh mit den anderen E-Mail Providern äh.
Im Falle der Telekom nicht, weil Telekom nimmt ja am so nicht äh teil. Das ist ja sozusagen alle außer Telekom, aber natürlich hat die Telekom mit den Großen ihre eigenen Peerings,
jeder große Anbieter in Deutschland hat eigene Leitungen zur Telekom,
Also hat einen eigenen Anknüpfungspunkt, den nicht das Dezix ist, weil sonst kriegst du den Traffic ja auch überhaupt gar nicht kanalisiert
so, ne? Und das ist halt, sagen wir mal, die Sonderstellung der Telekom, weil sie halt so groß sind, lassen sie sich halt auch so was wie Detexts gar nicht erst ein. Ja, die sind ihr eigener Tricks und äh sollen sie doch alle zu ihnen kommen so. Und,
Das ist aber auch gegeben und was was wollen sie denn dann tun? Wollen sie dann die Mail nicht verschicken? Das einfach Blödsinn.
Na, sie wollen irgendwie sicherstellen, dass,
Also ich ich würde auch sagen oder ich ich kann's nicht so weit nachvollziehen. Ich glaube, dass sie bis jetzt keine Maßnahmen ergriffen haben, um absolut auszuschließen, dass die Mail mal eine andere Route nimmt. Oder die die Verbindung, ja?
Von ihren Mailserver zu den anderen deutschen Mailservern.
Ja vor allem das.
Und das ist das, was sie jetzt dann tun werden, dass sie sagen, wir machen jetzt feste Routen und stellen sicher, dass nur dadurch geroutet wird.
Ja, aber ich meine, wie wollen sie denn das bitte sicherstellen? Wenn ich jetzt eine Mail an tralala Punkt tralala schicke. So, was, was wollen sie denn jetzt machen? Wollen sie die Mail nicht zustellen.
Aber zumindest zwischen den Deutschen.
Zwischen den deutschen Domains. Ja, aber das tun sie doch bestimmt eh.
Das ist die Frage,
Also stellen sie, haben sie nur halbwegs vernünftig ihre E-Mail-Server konfluiert, dass die wissen, wo sie langgehen müssen, um um wohin zu kommen?
Oder haben sie das bis jetzt nicht gemacht und sagen einfach, ja, da ist Internet äh und wir werfen das da jetzt rein und das soll zu der und der IP gehen. Wir machen Namen Server, Look ab und gucken, wo der MX null Punkt äh GMX DE ist und.
Ja, dann läuft's eh auf IP-Adressen raus, die sie dann testen müssten und vor allem wissen sie ja noch nicht mal, wenn sie irgendwas irgendwo abliefern, ob das auch schon der letzte Punkt ist.
Also ein Mailserver, der annonciert wird, als ich nehme die Mail für die Domain an.
Ja, das könnten sie ja, na, das könnten sie ja unter den Deutschen klarstellen. Also, wenn sie reden jetzt nur wieder von ihren.
Sie reden auch nur von Providern. Sie reden nur von ich habe meine Mail bei eins und eins und ich habe auch eine Eins und Eins-Mailadresse. Und nicht, ich bin da Kunde und habe da mal eine Mail, aber ich habe meine eigene Domänen und.
Ja, ja, okay, das ist ja wieder ein anderer Punkt. Natürlich, es geht nur wieder um Werbung. Es ist genauso ein Ding, wie wie äh E-Mail made in Germany. Und jetzt sagen sie, okay, äh haha.
Nationales Netz.
Nationales Netz hängt keine NSA drin, hängt nur BND drin. Können wir garantieren.
Genau.
Die Arbeiten zwar mit denen zusammen.
Genau, wir haben da so einen digitalen Stacheldraht drum herum gezogen, da kann die Mail nicht raus.
Ja, also ich ich keine Ahnung, vielleicht ich glaube, wir also,
Sollen sie machen, wenn wenn sie, wenn sie bis jetzt noch nicht gemacht haben, wenn da, wenn da noch nicht irgendwie ökonomische Erwägungen, die auf den Trichter gebracht haben, dass sie
eventuell äh günstiger wäre, direkte statische Routen für für zentralen Verkehr zu haben.
Es sind auch alles, das sind doch alles nur nur Nebelkerzen. Also das das ist einfach ob ob die da jetzt da für für irgendwelche einzelnen Domains irgendwas gesondert arrangieren. Ich meine, das garantiert einfach nichts,
Es garantiert einfach gar,
Nichts. Leute kommunizieren die ganze Zeit mit irgendjemanden, die irgendwelche Domains haben auf irgendwelchen Servern, irgendwelchen Diensten, die irgendwo im Internet sind und da kann die Telekom gar nicht sicherstellen, weil was was wollen sie denn dann,
sicherstellen, ja, es ist gar nix sichergestellt. Du hast halt irgendwelche E-Mail-Partner und die sind halt irgendwo im Internet und da ran ändert sich auch gar nichts. Und nur, weil sie sicherstellen, dass wenn du an eins und eins schickst, ja,
Dass dann ausnahmsweise mal nicht äh über irgendein äh Internetkabel geht, was es wahrscheinlich sowieso schon nicht äh wäre,
Was ist damit gewonnen? Gar nichts. Nischt.
Ich habe jetzt mal, ich will jetzt nochmal äh ganz kurz, ich habe jetzt gerade mal ganz kurz hier im Chat nachgefragt, ja oh,
Also Menschen, die sich auskennen, sagen, es ist eventuell tatsächlich davon auszugehen, dass sie bisher durchs Ausland nach nebenan routen.
Welches Ausland? Ist ferne.
Das ferne Ausland.
Also ich, ich kann's mir nicht, ich kann's mir nicht vorstellen, aber äh ich hätte mir auch nicht vorstellen können, dass sie ihren Transportweg nicht verschlüsseln. Insofern.
Ja, na gut, man kann sich äh manches nicht äh vorstellen, aber selbst wenn das so sein sollte und sie das ändern, ist auch nicht viel gewonnen. Das ist halt äh schon wirklich irgendwie alles ein bisschen problematisch,
Wollen wir das jetzt noch weiter vertiefen oder denkst du, wir kriegen ja jetzt noch rein? Unsere Experten, die Telefone glühen heiß, ja, im Hintergrund sehen sie.
Ich habe da wirklich ein äh.
Jemand der Ahnung hat im Gegensatz zu uns?
Also jemand, der jemand, der Ahnung hat, der auch äh äh sagt ähm okay, bei den bei den Deutschen, also,
teilt eigentlich genau deine Einschätzung. Bei den äh dass sie natürlich nicht eine Liste der deutschen E-Mail Provider pflegen und sicherstellen, dass bei jedem einzelnen Deutschen E-Mail-Provider,
sie ihre Mails dann auch nur durch Deutschland drohten. Es kann sehr gut sein, dass sie quasi zwischen den beiden, zwischen den sehr,
zwischen bekannten, großen, anderen E-Mail Providern dann schon irgendwie die direkte, eine direkte Route haben. Das wäre ihnen theoretisch zuzutrauen, dass sie äh so schlau sind.
Ist schön. Jetzt äh hast du mich zumindest nicht als totalen äh Interidioten
dastehen lassen. Der in Echtzeit von der Internetexperten aus dem Wildschwein korrigiert wird. Das freut mich doch sehr. Ein ein Restleumund bleibt.
So ein bisschen wirr.
Gut, das erzeugt alles äh Kopfschmerzen. Lass uns mal äh weitermachen.
Ja
Da kriegt noch jemand Kopfschmerzen.
Du hattest, ja, der hat jetzt ähm Tor,
Vorbereitet der NSA-Kopfschmerzen. Das war jetzt dann doch mal eine äh eines der Snowden League, die dann äh ja Leute doch auch mal äh ein bisschen beruhigt hat auch wieder, ja. Ähm
und zwar das äh anonymisierungsnetzwerk Tor ist sicherlich ähm,
Vielen unserer Hörerinnen bekannt. Ähm es gibt auch ein CRE darüber mit Arthur. Äh,
Ist her, aber äh am Grundprinzip hat sich nichts geändert. Ähm.
Hast du das gehört.
Ich habe alle CIs gehört.
Entschuldigung.
Bis auf die ersten, wo da irgendwie die ganze Zeit diese diese unerträgliche Mucke im Hintergrund.
Im Gegensatz zu mir, erinnerst du dich wahrscheinlich auch noch an den Inhalt?
Tor ähm eine Open-Source Software, die nach einem relativ einfachen Prinzip funktioniert, nämlich, dass mein Traffic.
Durch drei Stellen geroutet wird. Ähm,
mindestens und zwar so, dass ich immer nur,
Ähm also so dass dieser Traffic auch dreimal verschlüsselt ist. Das heißt, irgendwie die erste Person, an die ich mich wende, also die erste Station, an die ich mich wende, der sage ich nur, hier ist ein verschlüsseltes Paket, geb das mal der nächsten Station,
Diese nächste Station bekommt dieses Paket, weiß ja aber dann nicht mehr, dass es von mir kam,
Und gibt es dann an die Station weiter, die es am Ende dann äh für mich an das Internet ausliefert?
Das heißt, der die erste Person weiß oder die erste Station weiß, wer ich bin. Die zweite Station kennt weder den Inhalt, noch mich, die dritte Station kennt den Inhalt meiner Kommunikation, weiß aber nicht, wo sie herkam.
Ähm und wenn man das jetzt so spielt, dass diese drei Stationen auf beispielsweise unterschiedlichen Kontinenten liegen,
Hat man eine sehr hohe Wahrscheinlichkeit, äh dass es keinen, dass es keinen,
Allmächtigen Geheimdienst gibt, der alle drei,
Stationen überwacht und deshalb korrelieren kann und erkennt dass das, was da am anderen Ende an der Exit Not rauskommt, von mir an die Entry Note geworfen wurde.
Ich denke, ich hoffe, das habe ich jetzt halbwegs vernünftig.
Ist ein kompliziertes Thema. Ich will nur mal kurz auf diesen CRE äh verweisen. Ich hatte, das war nämlich einer, wo ich nachträglich nochmal den Titel geändert habe, der äh heißt nämlich eigentlich nur Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Da war zwar Tor ein Thema, aber es stand nicht so unbedingt total äh im Mittelpunkt. Das könnte nochmal passieren. Ähm,
CRI einundfünfzig.
Nee.
Doch. Also sie werden noch mal eins Nachrichtendiensten. Der war dann äh neunundfünfzig, jetzt auch nicht. Äh der ist dann erst zwanzig zehn. War das Tor irgendwie auch noch ein Thema? Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, nee.
Ja, das braucht auf jeden Fall nochmal ein Update.
Okay, ja, CRE.
Das aus dem November zweitausendsieben ist schon ein bisschen her. Ja ja.
So und jetzt ist es äh ist es der Hintergrund von Thor ist eigentlich, dass das Ding oder dieses dieses Prinzip,
des Zwiebel-Rutens, also die mehreren Schalen der Verschlüsselung und der äh,
Dieser Verbunden werden zu einer zu einem äh zu einem Routing, was dann eben äh ermöglichen soll, dass der ähm dass die Seite, die ich aufrufe in der Regel wird's ja für für Web Traffic benutzt, eben nicht mehr weiß, wer ich bin,
Ähm das wurde ursprünglich von der US-Regierung entwickelt, entwickelt, gelassen.
Ja, also es ist ein Projekt, was relativ viel Funding ähm ich glaube ursprünglich sogar im im Militär Hintergrund äh entwickelt wurde von Roger Dingeldein und.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Inzwischen ähm,
stark oder hauptsächlich finanziert durch so Internetfreiheit, Pfand äh äh die dann auch irgendwie am Ende äh Geld aus äh Hillary Clintons,
Budget haben so ungefähr, ja? Das heißt die USA haben relativ viele Aktien im Tor,
Aber das sollte der ganzen Sache ja kein Abbruch tun, weil es sich ja um ein Open-Source-Projekt handelt. Und man gerade bei Thor davon ausgehen kann, dass es wirklich von Leuten auch ausreichend,
gelesen und kontrolliert wird. Ähm,
Jetzt kann ich natürlich hingehen als Geheimdienst und sagen, naja, ich betreibe einfach mal eine Tor Exit-Note und überwachte den Traffic, der quasi da rauskommt und schau da einfach mal rein. Das wird auch gemacht,
Kann auch jeder machen, kann auch jeder selber machen. Dauert zehn Minuten, hast du eine Exit-Note. Dauert dann noch mal vierundzwanzig Stunden, hast du den ersten Brief von von ähm weil irgendjemand Scheiße dadrüber gebaut hat. Ähm,
Aber der entscheidende Punkt ist, schafft es, ein Geheim oder die entscheidende Frage ist, schafft es einen Geheimdienst, alle diese Nutzer zu deinonymisieren? Und das äh, wie sich jetzt herausstellt, schafft,
Selbst die NSA nicht. Und das ist erstmal eine gute Nachricht.
Also offenbar nicht, weil sie nämlich Probleme hatten, bestimmte User zu finden, an denen sie ein Interesse hatten.
Genau, sie sagen aber gleichzeitig, sie sind in der Lage, ähm,
einzelne Nutzer gezielt anzugreifen. Da gibt's jetzt also in letzter Zeit hast du immer wieder Meldungen über ähm,
irgendwelche Menschen, also Tor wird natürlich auch von äh von äh Kriminellen genutzt, wie jede andere Technologie, die der Menschheit zur Verfügung steht auch, wird auch Tor von Kriminellen genutzt. Ähm.
Und es gab dann, gibt dann immer mal wieder irgendwie Verhaftung, äh wo dann irgendwelche, ja, Leute gezielt angegriffen werden, die bestimmte Seiten besucht haben und man
vor ein paar Monaten gab's eine größere Lücke in Firefox, die es ermöglicht hatte, aus an Tor vorbei zu ruhten,
Das heißt, ich bin als Tornutzer auf eine Seite gekommen, dann äh hat eine Schwäche in meinem Browser dazu geführt, dass ich außerhalb von Thor einmal mich kurz gegenüber der NSA identifiziert habe,
So haben sie dann ähm ich glaube, das war so eine äh Pädophilen-Ring oder sowas hochgenommen.
Ähm aber das heißt, die quasi der Routing Teil von Thor selber ist sicher gegenüber der,
Gegenüber einer Massenüberwachung durch die NSA, gezielte Angriffe auf einzelne Personen oder Nutzergruppen oder hidden Services
gelingen aber teilweise nicht nur der NSA, sondern sogar dem FBI regelmäßig. Und da hatten wir jetzt gerade diesen,
Fall äh von Silk Road, einem Online Marktplatz, der äh als hidden Service äh betrieben wurde. Das heißt, ähm,
Bei einem,
Hin Service ist es so, dass quasi auch die Zielstelle sich in diesem Tor Netzwerk verbirgt, das heißt, ich kann einen einen Server betreiben, von dem man nicht herausfinden kann, wo er steht,
der ist dann nur über Tor erreichbar,
und äh wenn ich keine besonders schwerwiegenden Fehler in meiner äh Operational Security mache, wird es schwer möglich sein, zu identifizieren, zu identifizieren, wo dieses Gerät steht.
Trotzdem scheint das jetzt im Falle von stattgefunden zu haben, allerdings eben auch nicht eben über Tor direkt, sondern über andere Fehler, die dieser Betreiber äh gemacht hat.
Der Betreiber hat eine ganze Menge äh Fehler gemacht und einer davon war, dass er ähm als er
quasi gerade äh fertiggestellt hatte, dass in irgendeinem Forum bekanntgegeben hat und in diesem Forum seinen Nutzernamen registriert hatte, auf eine GG-Mail-Adresse, die auf seinen richtigen Namen lautete.
Das heißt, er hat in irgendeinen in irgendeinen Drogenfond gesagt, ey cool hier äh online äh Dingens äh ne. So und äh das FBI hat halt mit langen Recherchen und viel Suche und,
diesen Menschen dann ähm.
Ausfindig gemacht.
Ausfindig gemacht, äh weil er eben irgendwie sein damals bekannt machen musste. Ähm,
Außerdem hatte er, glaube ich, auch mal äh bei Steck Overflow eine Frage gestellt und sich da unter seinem richtigen Namen angemeldet. Ähm,
inzwischen hatte dieser Typ aber,
achtzig Millionen Dollar Provision kassiert über seinen kleinen äh Online-Marktplatz. Ähm hatte gerade zweieinhalb Millionen auf dem Treue,
toller, ja? Ist jetzt umgerechnet in Dollar. Zweiein äh zweieinhalb Millionen Dollar in Bitcoin auf seinem Treuhänderkonto,
was für die also er bietet einen Treuhandservice an da wurden also jetzt zweieinhalb Millionen US-Dollar.
Was heißt, er bietet einen Treuhandservice an für Bitcoin sozusagen.
Also du musst dir, es ist ja, es ist ja komplett anonym. Also du gehst bei hin, das ist wie so ein Forum. Da steht einer und sagt, ich verkaufe jetzt hier Droge A, zu der und der Menge,
äh zu dem mit dem Preis. So und dann muss ja irgendwie ein Handel,
zustande kommen. So. Das Schöne an Ziel Code ist, keiner kann da es nur über Tor erreichbar ist, weiß weder der Seitenbetreiber, wer die Leute sind, die da,
Sachen anbieten. Äh noch wissen die, wer er ist, ja? Aber irgendwann kommt ja der Punkt, wo zumindest der Käufer sagen muss, schicke an diese Adresse.
Geld oder an diese.
Na, der Käufer sagt ja, schicke Drogen an dieser Adresse. Und ähm jetzt hast du aber diesen vollständig anonymen illegalen Handel,
Und du musst ja irgendwie eine eine Form von Vertrauen da reinbringen. Und das machen sie einerseits über oder haben sie gemacht über Nutzerkommentare, das heißt irgendwie bestellst da und schreibst sie nachher hin, ja hier eins A, ne, hat gut geknallt oder so,
und äh habe mal habe auch bekommen, was ich bestellt habe. So und um um dieses Problem zu äh äh.
Drogenhändler gerne wieder.
Top Cycroder, gerne wieder.
Ähm um, um, um diesen Problem entgegen zu wirken, hat,
Der Typ dann eben auch gegen natürlich gegen Provision ein Treuhandkonto angeboten und hat gesagt, so wir machen das so, du kaufst jetzt irgendwie äh Menge X und dann überweist du die Bitcoins erstmal an mich,
Und in dem Moment, wo du dann die Drogen bekommen hast, bestätigst du online, dass du die erhalten hast und ich überweise dann das Geld an den Verkäufer.
Mhm. Das heißt, die Kohle musste er schon mal abdrücken, aber der Verkäufer hat's erst bekommen, wenn der andere gesagt hat, alles super. Und dann wird aber eine gewisse Provision abgezogen und davon hat er sich sozusagen.
Davon hat der geschätzte alleine an den Provisionen, hat der geschätzte achtzig Millionen,
Dollar eingestrichen. Und wenn wenn der Grade auf nur auf diesem Treuhänder Wallet quasi nur Geld
was da liegt und gerade darauf wartet, von von dem von den jeweiligen Händlern in Empfang genommen zu werden. Wenn er da allein zweieinhalb Millionen äh US-Dollar draufliegen hatte, kannst dir ungefähr vorstellen, von was für einem Ausmaß dieses Ding war.
War denn die Provision? Weiß man das?
Weiß ich jetzt nicht, könnte man nochmal gucken aber wird wahrscheinlich,
weiß ich nicht, habe da nie irgendwas gekauft. Aber äh Betrieb äh das das Ding selber war schon irgendwie.
Nach Milliardengeschäft.
Eine ziemlich geile äh Sache. Achtzig Millionen US-Dollar ist übrigens ziemlich genau das Geld, was äh Walter White ähm bei Breaking Bad am Ende hatte.
Ähm.
So und jetzt der Typ, man könnte jetzt sagen, ja, irgendwie cooler Typ, hat irgendwie eine, hat einen Online-Marktplatz gemacht, so ähm,
Leider wurden auf nicht nur äh nicht nur Drogen gehandelt, sondern auch so Heckservices und äh Auftragsmorde.
Und da irgendein ehemaliger Unterstützer des Servers.
Mit äh dem FBI oder irgendwie in Huff war oder so, hat dann der Red Pirat Robert, der Silk Road Founder,
über dessen Ermordung bestellt? Ja
und der Fall wurde damit abgehandelt, dass er, na, hat irgendwie so, ich geb dir die Hälfte jetzt und die Hälfte, wenn's vorbei ist und dann haben, hat das FBI äh gestellte Fotos von Folterung und äh äh Mord der betroffenen Person
den geschickt und hat auch die Kohle bekommen.
Aber es war kein wirklicher Mord, sondern.
Der Mord ist nicht geschehen, aber der hat einen Mord beauftragt.
Der Beauftragte war das FBI selber. Also die.
Die hatten da quasi schon irgendwie ihre Finger drin.
Also ist nur da hat hat nur das FBI dort die Dienstleistung ermordung, angeboten oder war das jetzt rein zufällig, dass sie nur.
Nee, nee, das, nee, nee, nee, er hat er hat ähm also der Fall ist da noch nicht, ich habe das also er hat tatsächlich einen anderen beauftragt,
Und dieser hätte diese äh hat diese Dienstleistung auch angeboten und war nicht vom FBI,
und irgendwie ist das FBI dann irgendwo dazwischen gekommen. Äh wie gesagt, da,
Eventuell hatten sie den halt schon identifiziert und äh trojanisiert oder so. Äh,
So, also das wird dann da noch eine sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr ekelhafte Geschichte. Und ähm.
Oh Mann, von dem wird uns aber nicht viel übrig bleiben, ne?
Von dem Mann wird nicht viel übrig bleiben und jetzt gehen grade ähm,
überall, also in Schäden und in USA, in in UK, gehen jetzt auch weitere Verhaftungen los von Menschen, die also über Handel betrieben haben,
Aber, wie gesagt, die werden alle äh nicht identifiziert über über eine generelle Schwäche des Tornetzwerks, sondern hauptsächlich eben durch gezielte Angriffe.
Und was so ähm.
Auch die Frage, ne, was hat der Pirat Robert selber für Informationen vorliegen? Ist ja jetzt nicht wenig, ne? Also wenn's jetzt wirklich äh.
Naja, es ist Tor, er weiß, er er kann also in äh das Schöne an dem Tor hin Service ist, dass das Ding eigentlich auch nicht in der Lage sein sollte, ähm irgendwie seine Kunden zu verraten.
Weil es ja nur über Tor äh, weil nur über Tor darauf zugegriffen wurde,
Jetzt kann natürlich sein, dass der irgendwie in diesem eine riesige Datenbank von Käuferadressen jetzt da noch auf der Büchs liegen hat, die jetzt im in der in den Händen des FBI.
Ist nicht ganz ausgeschlossen.
FBI hat dann natürlich auch sich über über Postwege äh äh sind die natürlich dann auch den den Absendern äh auf die Spur gekommen. Da gab's dann irgendwie ein ein Paar, was irgendwie regelmäßig eine Runde über dreißig äh
äh Postämter gefahren ist, weil die eine riesen Menge an Drogen verschicken mussten, ja und dann hatten sie halt ein GPS-Sender unter ihr Auto geklickt und,
wie die jeden Tag eine Runde fuhren, um eben jedem Postamt ein Paket abzusenden, ne, damit nicht auffällt, dass sie da auf einmal mit paar Kilo Heroin reinkommen und ähm,
und solche Sachen. Also äh da das ist das liest sich alles sehr spannend. Ähm wie da so die Ermittlungs äh Methoden waren und,
Äh ist echt äh ich glaube, das wird nicht lange dauern, bis das vielleicht nochmal irgendwie verfilmt wird oder so,
Ist auf jeden Fall alles alles mit drin für für einen ordentlichen, für einen ordentlichen Film,
traurige Silkwort ist weg, ja? Und äh was selbst das FBI bestätigte
ist, ähm dass der äh das auf Coota Stoff gedealt wurde, weil die hätten also hundert Probebestellungen gemacht und ähm haben festgestellt, dass da dass die Ware da ähm erstens ankommt und zweitens auch die versprochene war.
Ja, soweit ich das äh gehört habe, gibt's keinen Mangel an Nachahmerprojekten, die jetzt äh unter neuen Namen ähnliche Dienste anbieten.
Nö, ist jetzt ja auch keine Hexerei irgendwie, ne? Und wenn du siehst, was du da für für für Gewinn mitmachen kannst, ist das ja auch äh naheliegend vielleicht so ein Marktplatz äh zu starten.
Für Ermordungen und Folter.
Ja, also das ist echt.
Schon ein bisschen hart.
Ist echt eine ein bisschen hart, ja,
Ja, Tor, lang, lange, lange, spannende Geschichte des des Deep Webs und äh ist natürlich auch offene Weise wieder schade, dass das,
Dass das jetzt grade so in den Medien ist, weil Tor eben, wie gesagt, äh das ist mir auch immer wichtig zu betonen für Menschen in,
in äh anderen Ländern eine sehr wichtige Möglichkeit ist, äh.
Überhaupt zu kommunizieren? Absolut.
Wobei ich kleine Anekdote, wir haben mal ähm nee, die erzähle ich jetzt nicht. Äh also Thor ist,
Tor ist wichtig, äh brauchen wir und ähm,
Ich kann auch äh möchte auch alle äh Hörerinnen und Hörer motivieren äh tour relays aufzusetzen. Das dauert nicht lange
und eure Server, die vielleicht so ein bisschen Webservi machen oder sowas
und Unmengen an freien Kapazitäten haben, sowohl an CPU als auch an Bandbreite, das kann man relativ schnell und einfach einrichten, dass sie ein bisschen bei Tor Traffic mit Routen.
Und ein Relaye äh bringt einem jetzt auch nicht diese Briefe ein.
Genau. Also Exit-Note betreiben äh nur für Fortgeschrittene. Ähm,
Relay ist also quasi entweder der Eingang oder das Teil in der Mitte, was nur irgendwie verschlüsselte Sachen hin und her schiebt und das äh kann man sehr schnell machen, ist relativ einfach,
und ähm man kann dann da auch irgendwie so angeben, wie viel Bandbreite man äh geben möchte oder so Volumengrenzen besetzen, damit äh setzen, damit man nicht irgendwie das outmaxt, was man so beim Provider hat. Ich habe mal,
das hat irgendwie zwanzig einundzwanzig Terabyte,
im Monat durch die Gegend geschoben, da hab ich dann Ärger bekommen mit meinem Provider,
Der hat dann gesagt, das geht so nicht. Weil ich unlimited Traffic hatte, ja gut, hätte er mir nicht geben sollen, hatte. Wusste halt nicht, dass ich äh die den Traffic genau nehme und äh benutze.
Ich habe nur das verbraucht, was mir angeboten wurde.
Für drei Euro achtzig im Monat. Aber genau, kann man, kann man machen, Tor ist cool,
und der wichtige Punkt natürlich Thor ist nicht die das Allheilmittel, weil in dem Moment, wo ihr euch über Tor äh auf eure Facebook-Seite einloggt, ähm ist es mit eurer Anonymität ohnehin vorbei, weil ihr ja,
Facebook gegenüber eurer Identität offenbart, ja? Das heißt, äh Thor ist ein ähm ein Werkzeug, welches man mit Bedacht,
nutzen sollte, wenn man mit sensiblen Dingen umgeht. So lang genug über Tor geredet.
Gut, was haben wir noch?
Es gibt nochmal was vom Europäischen Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte. Und dieses Mal ähm,
geht es um eine Klage und zwar von Big Brother Watch, der Open Rides Group, der englischen Schriftstellervereinigung Pen und Konstanze Kurz.
Hm, was für eine illustre äh Runde.
Die klagen gegen die britische Regierung. Und zwar hatten die äh die die drei englischen Organisationen,
ursprünglich versucht, ihre Klage gegen den GCA Q, also den britischen Geheimdienst und seine Überwachungsmethoden ähm,
bei einem ein britischen Gericht vorzulegen und ähm da hatte dann die ähm,
War dann die Aussage, mehr britische Gerichte werden den Fall nicht bearbeiten. Äh wendet euch doch an die parlamentarische Geheimdienstkontrolle,
Also das Gremium, was diese ganzen Sachen anordnet und im Geheimen äh darüber entscheidet. Das heißt, und dessen äh äh Ergebnisse nicht anfechten, nicht gerichtlich anfechtbar sind, mit anderen Worten haben die Briten gesagt, es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
dagegen zu klagen gegen das, was hier passiert. Also haben die Organisation gesagt, wenn wir ähm,
In Großbritannien kein äh kein keine Klage dagegen einrichten können, kein keine Klage dagegen einreichen können, die äh der Öffentlichkeit zugänglich ist,
dann äh wenden wir uns doch mal an.
Europäischen Gerichtshof, beziehungsweise für den für Menschenrechte. Ja, um es kurz mal klarzustellen, also Konstanze, äh Sprecherin des CCC, als sie selbst nimmt daran teil, nicht der CCC als solcher.
Das hat äh verschiedene Gründe.
Ja, sicherlich. Auf jeden Fall, das ist jetzt schon.
Unter anderem, glaube ich, weil du betroffene Personen brauchtest und nicht Organisationen.
Okay, das ist jetzt erfolgt.
Diese Klage wurde eingereicht,
und ähm das ist wie der CCC äh korrekt äh feststellt, vermutlich die erste Beschwerde äh bezüglich Prisum und Tempora vor einem internationalen Gericht.
Mhm, interessant. Aber das ist jetzt auch nicht sehr viel mehr passiert, als dass es ähm eingereicht wurde, die Klage.
Und jetzt wird man sehen, ob sie angenommen wird.
Mhm. Also das ist jetzt auch noch nicht erfolgt. Darauf wollte ich ja nicht hinaus. Also sozusagen wurde hingeschickt und jetzt.
Die ist jetzt da hingeschickt
und werden sie im Zweifelsfall annehmen und dann wird man sehen, was da was daraus passiert. Ja, weil sie sagen eben, dass diese Form der Überwachung eben nicht nicht akzeptabel ist. Und ich denke, dass da der EG ähm R
schon der guter Ansprechpartner ist.
Ja, weil sie sich ja auch schon so kompetent über Internet-Kommentare geäußert haben.
Ja, da haben sie sich natürlich sehr gut geäußert. Also es ist äh ich meine, du musst ja, du du musst ja irgendwann machen, also ähm ich finde das finde das eine eine finde das gut.
Interessant für dich, dass ausgerechnet die englische Schriftstellervereinigung sich daran äh beteiligt.
Also jetzt auch, weil sie sich da betroffen sieht oder weil die da äh eine der wenigen ähm,
Intellektuellen, Subgruppen in Britannien noch sind, die sich überhaupt,
daran äh stören, dass das alles stattfindet, weil wenn man sich so die Medienschlacht derzeit anschaut, äh hat man so den Eindruck, äh alle gegen den Guardian und der Rest äh hält die Füße still. Das ist schon doch äh ein ziemlich starkes Stück, was da läuft.
Ja, das äh wie war das überhaupt? Also der Guardian hat jetzt äh aufs öffentlich,
bösartige Anschuldigungen über seine äh Veröffentlichung bekommen, ne? Das war in der Daily Mail oder was das war, wo sie sagten, ähm,
die ganzen Guardian-Veröffentlichungen helfen einfach nur Terroristen und haben keinen äh offensichtlicher, keine äh öffentliche politische Resonanz,
Und daraufhin veröffentlichte der Guardian jetzt äh die Statements von irgendwie den
Was weiß ich, den den führenden Chefredakteurin der großen europäischen Pressehäuser, die also dann dem dem Guardian zusprachen, dass er da äh journalistische äh,
Notwendigkeiten.
Also Worte der Unterstützung oder was? Ah ja, dann doch.
Unterstützung, ja. Ach so, sprachst du da gar nicht darauf an. Ich dachte, das wäre jetzt der.
Ich weiß es ja nicht, ich war ja im Urlaub, ich hab das jetzt so im Detail nicht verfolgt, ich weiß nur es gab irgendwie so etwas Merkwürdiges,
Interview hier mit BBC und dem wo sie auch also die ganze Zeit äh auf ihn eingeredet haben, was was sie mir einfallen würde und so weiter. Und man fragt sich halt auch wirklich, was denn eigentlich mit dem BBC los ist. So,
Also da ist schon eine interessante Solidarisierung äh auch äh ähm am Staat, ja, wie man sie bisher eigentlich so nur von, weiß nicht, ob man sie nur von Amerika äh USA her kannte oder ob,
man nur nicht so genau hingeschaut hat oder ob das jetzt erst etwas ist, was so in äh Britannien jetzt erstmal äh so stark,
das erste Mal, aber man hat jetzt nicht so den Eindruck
dass das Land im Aufruhr ist und äh die Pressefreiheit hier gefährdet sieht. Ich meine auch Deutschland äh haben wir ja nun äh auch in den letzten Wochen und Monaten hier ausführlich dokumentiert.
Macht nicht gerade so den Eindruck, als ob das Thema Pressefreiheit in der ganzen Debatte auch nur irgendjemand irgendwie interessieren würde, ja, oder äh Mandantenschutz oder äh irgendein anderer,
dieser äh Klassiker, die natürlich nicht nur die Vorratsdaten speichern, sondern eben auch durch eine Überwachung generell. Vor allem eine illegale, also nicht,
Gesetze gedeckte äh Überwachung bedrohte äh Maßnahme des.
Interessiert irgendwie keinen und das ist beunruhigend, um es mal zurückhaltend zu formulieren.
Insofern volle Unterstützung für für diese Klage, natürlich die ähm,
beste, besten Wunsch zum Erfolg. Also ich meine, das ist so die einzige, wahrscheinlich so das einzige, was man jetzt noch machen kann überhaupt als Reaktion darauf, ja, sich irgendwie kann man ja nur hoffen, dass da noch irgendwie eine,
Reaktionen. Also irgendwas, also ich meine, das wäre jetzt die einzige Institution, die eventuell da in der Lage ist, da überhaupt irgendwie äh zu einer Veränderung.
Das wird sehr interessant sein äh zu sehen, welche in welchem Blickwinkel die da drauf äh haben, beziehungsweise ob sie es überhaupt annehmen,
Das wäre dann äh auch insofern mal sehr interessant, dass einfach ähm auf europäischer Ebene oder überhaupt auf so einer Gerichtsebene Überwachung als solche oder geheimdienstliche Aktivität mal zum Thema gemacht wird.
So. Ja, ich wollte abschließend noch ähm,
sagen, wir haben äh vier äh Hörer der Woche und zwar sind das Christoph, Jochen, Sven und Jannes, die wissen wieso. Vielen Dank.
Genau, ein glücklicher Linos. Äh, das war's jetzt hier nach zwei Wochen äh Pause. Wir sind jetzt wieder da und machen weiter. Stimmt's?
So sieht's aus. Alles klar, das war's, bis bald und tschüss.
Ciao, ciao.